right Gloria Gloria wait for it
where'd you grow up I was born in
Lancaster at a bee Hospital
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents growing up my birth
mom abandoned me and she was on drugs
when I was an infant she that anything
happened to me like they did you know
finger me you know like when I was a
baby she was just sitting there just you
know watching to get the drugs because
she was you know desperate for it or
whatever and then I don't know how long
it was going and so she you know keep
you know always doing it to get the
drugs or whatever it is I'm selling you
out yeah basically you know laying
things happen to me and I guess my found
out so they took me from her so I was in
a lot of different foster homes getting
be shared with her on that four day and
like you know traumatize or whatever
then my breath mom found out that she
was pregnant with twins with my sister
and her twin brother and she was still
doing drugs and she was in a garage and
she gave birth to them tried to toss
them like there was trash and they she
put them in the trash bag toilet
tied him up and tried them you know
Charles them in the trash can and stuff
the neighbors saw so they called him one
she got arrested so she's doing life and
I don't know her first name and then I
don't know nothing about her I don't
know nothing by my father but my baby
brother didn't survive but she did like
she's 14 now you know she don't know she
a you know confused and stuff and you
know and I didn't even know until my
adopted mom told me we didn't know she
was our adoptive mom until she told us
when I was like Kyrie like seven years
old and she was like you know a little
younger every thought she was our birth
mom we feel bad side depressed like we
was wondering like who was our birth mom
what she looked like where we came from
churches she told uh it's in the snap
she told her that she gave she was born
in the garage I was burning it baby hi
baby
Hospital and stuff and then we was like
you know torn but at the same time you
know we gotta you know suck it up or
whatever and I was 14 or whatever my god
dad passed away before my 15 birthday it
was summer ties or whatever I didn't
know what to do
started thinking negative about myself
he was the only person I could open up
to go to and trust him a couple of days
later I found out my uncie passed away a
couple days later in my cousin passed
away like three deaths at once in
different months and year and stuff and
I thought I can't do it no more so I
start hanging out the wrong crowd
God just - we weed and alcohol so
drinking thought it was cool so ran away
from home
been on the street going back and forth
and I'd do whatever to you know to fit
in because I didn't know how to fit in I
was looking for love in the wrong places
and trusting guys got set up got a gun
put to my head twice forced me to you
know do stuff with guys to make money or
sell drugs if I don't do it they gonna
in my life were in my family life and I
didn't wanted that so I started doing
whatever I got a dude's order to keep my
family life and keep myself a life and
so I started selling drugs started
stealing from stores selling baby
clothes she was and all that and then
got caught up with my ex and for a
burglary died I didn't do so I went up
got locked up at 16 been in there for
like a month
got out on supposed to be on house
arrest but I didn't get our own house
arrest I went home me and my mom getting
an argument she was accusing me of
stealing her say you're accusing me of
not stealing her stuff out her room or
out the cabin there without asking and
every time my little sister do something
she'd blame me on me and I started
feeling some type of way
started like Oh nobody care about me
nobody loved me so I started splitting
my wrist I tried overdosed three times
didn't work I was like [ __ ] it whatever
and you know just you know bringing the
street-fighting left or right and and I
didn't like that and I regret it and
stuff but it's like it's really hard now
start writing poetry's you know telling
my story it's kind of hard to tell my
story because sometimes when I talk
about it I start crying a little bit
kind of hurt but sometimes I gotta suck
it up you know to let other people to
know that they're not alone because at
first I thought I was by myself I
thought I was alone I didn't know
anybody had anything to comment you know
I thought nobody believed me nobody
trusts me nobody cares and then that but
I do have somebody do care it's like
I've been pushing everybody that care
about me and love me and brung that
negative around me and push away that
positive and I realized that in October
11 2008 een I got reduced to Chris I was
depressed I was trying to in my life
that day but someone was I don't do that
just smoke this have fun so he was
controlling me every time you know he
had me smoking
he started ripping my clothes off start
you know doing stuff that I didn't
improve you get on top of me do whatever
he controlled me I can't leave out his
side he get mad when I'm talking to a
nun guy and I taught mom and I his
female he's claiming me and I finally
try to got away October 30th and that
day I try to overdose that day almost
died if I never got rushed to a hospital
I could have died that day and my doctor
mom found out she came out here came all
the way to Lancaster from Victorville to
get me talked to me telling me like why
are you doing these drugs I don't
understand why you can't talk to me you
could come and tell me anything but
that's
think I'm kind of scared to touch stuff
because I know how she gets she she
react over little things she get mad she
cuts me out she bring up the past she's
always saying oh you're hang on vision
you don't be like your birth mom doing
drugs on these streets or being in
prison you keep it up you need to like
you know fix your life around you have
suddenly your sister is looking up to
you
and then when she said that I started
breaking down like [ __ ] like I don't
want my sister go through the things
that I've been through I don't want no
kids go through the things that I've
been through because it's not right at
all cuz the things that I've been
through and she been through it's not
our fault it's our parents fault you
know by the same times like I forgive
them not for what they did but to order
to forgive to move on not try to hold
against them because we don't know what
made them to do that because they
probably was going through some things
they didn't know how to cope it the only
way that cope is doing drugs and drugs
don't get you nowhere at all so that's
how I feel and hurt and all that so
today we're in a tent chatter that's
good room in a skid row yeah using
crystal meth doing crystal meth what do
you do for money now I Panhandle or
funny if I can't do what I need to do
I probably send my body only like once
or twice that's it that I that I know of
and I'm scared to do that again yeah and
your name family or friends I mean my
family they kind of talk to me but they
barely talk to me now because of my
adopted mom cuz wherever she if I know
what I do and the drugs that I do they
don't my family don't mess with me
because the drugs I'm doing and they
want the best for me but they don't want
me around them when I'm on drugs or
stuff they saying if I could get myself
clean get the help I need to order just
coming back around the fam
what do you think about your who is the
biggest factor in your childhood that
kind of set you like this path you think
that main station are there the whole
station I'm not being around there dad
the whole station cuz I feel like a part
of me is missing but I can't actually no
worry about that but myself and my best
mom because ever since that day what she
did to me and my siblings I've been lost
unsure don't know what's going on I want
answers but I don't know how i'ma get it
though from her don't know if she's
still alive from not I was scared to
look for her scared to know who she
really is
I'm scared to be running up like her I
know I could do better
he's smarter than that and doing
anything I could my mind so you're I'm
only 18 we write you
and you have a boyfriend yes I do he's
good you were our relationship is really
good we get annoying my hair in there
you know little ups and downs but you
know he always treat me right he made
sure I'm safe
you know nothing harm me and then he's
the only guy that ever trust jacker to
talk to me have been best friend for two
years and I don't know where we finally
found out we had like to each other and
name we got together we were you like to
be in a couple years I'm get any plans
for doing anything to get officers off
the streets that I haven't think of you
but I was thinking to put my poetry out
there like that or put it on Facebook
making something to put her out on
Facebook to let everybody see on
Facebook and let them know that never
give up because if you give up you don't
know if you could achieve your goals
because how you're achieve your goals if
you give up keep trying even though if
you feel get back up and keep going
whatever is in the past wherever you
been through it's not your fault just
keep going and that's all I got to say
even even let me on the streets for how
long ago since I was 14 till till I'm 18
now yeah how do you think that this for
years have affected you it affected me a
lot
you know but I'm staying strong the best
I can to order to let people know that
I'm strong I could conquer my goals and
not affect not think about the pain even
though I could feel the pain even though
I could think about it here and there
try not to think about it best I can
right Gloria thank you for coming in and
talk with
you